the singleton design pattern limits the
number of instances of a particular
object to just one the single instance
is called the singleton this is useful
when exactly one object is needed to
coordinate actions across the system you
may use a singleton as the source of
config settings for a web app or on the
client side for anything initiated with
an API key Singleton's also serve as a
shared resource namespace which isolate
implementation code from the global
namespace so as to provide a single
point of access for functions namespace
in your code is a primary use of
Singleton's a well-known use case for
this is jQuery jQuery itself is a
singleton because Singleton's involve a
global instance many people don't like
them but it's important to know about
them there are many ways to create a
singleton I'm going to explain one
implementation of a singleton that comes
from areas Manny's book learning
JavaScript design patterns so we're
gonna create the singleton here as this
function and we are going to create a
variant instant a variable called
instance that stores a reference to the
singleton now we are going to create
what properties and functions are inside
the singleton here so first we're going
to create the private methods and
variables now this is basically just an
example of how it would work but
anything here are gonna be the private
methods and variables we have the
private method which just there's a
console that log I in private with our
private variable I am also private
private random number with we just get a
random number so none of these methods
and variables can be accessed from the
singleton instance they can only be
accessed from within the singleton so
here are the public methods and
variables so public method is a function
console a lot of the public and steamy
and the public property I am also a
public get random number function
returned prior to random number so
that's the only way that you can get to
the private functions and methods and
variables is if one of these public
methods and variables references it so
they get random number
public method is going to reference the
private random number variable and
that's how you can get access to it down
here is where you're going to get the
instance of the singleton so all of this
could let me go back up for a second all
this code is in this init function this
init function returns all the things
that the singleton is going to do and
then down here as part of the singleton
you are going to run the init function
to get the instance of the singleton the
only function on the singleton variable
up here is get instance now this is a
public function table method and this
this function is going to say if there
is no instance if an instance has been
created then instance equals in it where
we're gonna run that init function up
here and it's going to give us all this
all this however if a function as if an
instance has already been created we're
just gonna return the instance that's
been created so let's go down and show
how you would use this here's where
we're going to create an instance of the
singleton var single a equals my
singleton dot get instance var single B
equals my singleton get instance
now this get instance is going to give
us the same instance as before the way
we're going to demonstrate it is this
this random number math dot random so
each instance should have a completely
different random number inside so first
I'm gonna just show single a dot public
method is just a method up here that
says the public can see me and then
catalog single that a public property
it's just gonna do the I am also public
now here's where we're gonna see that
they're the same instance console dot
log single a get random number equals
equals equals single be get random
number so different instances should
have different random numbers so if
they're the same and since this should
show is true so I'm going to run that
and look the publicans see me I am also
public and true they are both the same
instance so we can create as many
instances instances as we want but
they're all the exact same instance well
thanks for watching check the links in
the descriptions for more information
about Singleton's my name is beau Carnes
don't forget to subscribe and remember
use your code for good